[Musique]
nous avons simplement
[Applaudissements]
cette année en fait on a énormément de
population on appelle pacte ils savent
annuler personnes qui sont sans papiers
dans l'esprit sont souvent lamentables
les migrants ou sur 1300 ses portes de
paris depuis c'est nous tout ce monde
malgré son patrice endroit pour ça pèse
surtout sur toutes les chaussées de
certaines fleurs sur le vivre ensemble
puisque arrêt total dans les temps sont
très très différentes avec des écarts
énormes entre les populations et en même
temps sur le 200 m de mieux du travail
puisque une partie des sympathisants
pour être halal quand même beaucoup et
notion interview exploitation du fait de
leur statut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mona le concours a détaillé l'espagne à
régulariser des sans papiers
france que ça moi qui n'étais pas prêt
mais li l'a cette maladie là c'est nous
qui nettoyait le losc les hôpitaux et
centres d'aidé benzema autour de toi et
tout donc on veut demander à l'état
français de faire comme d'espagne et
vitalité
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]